[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم قوات الاحتلال تشن عمليه
دهم وملاحقه في مناطق بالضفه الغربيه بحثا
عن منفذ هجوم حواره في نابلس الذي اسفر عن
مقتل اسرائيليين واصيب خلال عمليه الدعم
مستوطن بيران قوه من الجيش قرب قريه دبا
الشرقيه ظنا انه فلسطيني نتنياهو يتوعد
بالقضاء على منفذ الهجوم بينما تحذر
السلطه الفلسطينيه من شعار محو حواره
وتحمل المجتمع الدولي المسؤوليه بعد عقده
لقاءات مع الرئيس المحتجز وقاده الانقلاب
يغادر عاصمه النيجر ومصادر تقول ان المجلس
العسكري اكد لوفد المجموعه رفضه اعاده
بازوم للسلطه وطالب برفع العقوبات في حين
يقول اعضاء الوفد الافريقي ان اللقاءات
يمكن ان تشكل منطلقا لحل الازمه اضراب في
العديد من بلدات ومناطق محافظه السوي
الجنوبيه سوريا احتجاجا على ترد الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه في البلاد حيث شمل الاضراب
اغلاق معظم الدوائر الحكوميه واقفال
المحال التجاريه وقطع الطرق المؤديه الى
مراكز المدن والبلدات كما نظم الاهالي
وقفه الاحتجاجيه في ساحه السير وسط
السويدا اسبانيا تتوج بلقب كاس العالم
للسيدات للمره الاولى في تاريخها بعد
فوزها على انجلترا بهدف دون رد في
المباراه النهائيه التي اقيمت في استراليا
وقد سجلت قائدته منتخب لاروخا اولغا
كارمونا هدف الفوز في الدقيقه التاسعه
والعشرين الى اللقاء